some of the hardest-hit people by Donald
Trump's tariffs are soybean farmers
soybeans are a really really big deal
12% of American exports to China or
soybeans according to the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology China wanted a
ton of soybeans historically
increasingly so farmers were producing
more and more and there's now a new
study which points out that soybean
sales to China are down 94 percent from
the United States as a result of Donald
Trump's tariffs and this is a really key
point Trump doesn't even understand that
when we put tariffs on Chinese goods he
talks about we're putting tariffs that
China is paying for no we're not China
doesn't pay those tariffs we are when we
buy stuff from them which we need to do
because when we stopped getting source
materials and components from China the
end products being created by American
companies get more expensive the costs
are passed to the consumers that's one
side of the equation the other side of
the equation is that China buy stuff
from us but they've stopped buying
soybeans because of the retaliatory
tariffs that china has put on the united
states responding to Trump's tariffs so
they're going elsewhere for soybeans and
the losers are who our farmers as the
corporations that do manufacturing are
also increasingly losers under these
tariffs and you might say well David
you're cherry-picking why are you
focusing on just soybeans in China it's
it's anecdotal well China is a top
consumer of soybeans by a huge amount if
you look at the list which we have up on
the screen for you you will see that
China is I mean it's it's just not even
close by how much China is the top
consumer of soybeans and the United
States is or at least was before these
tariffs one of the biggest exporters of
soybeans in the world behind Brazil
unclear how Trump's tariffs are going to
impact those numbers and what's the
solution that they claim to have come up
with in the meantime while the tariffs
farmers this is it's the stuff of comic
books almost the Trump administration
says well we will subsidize farmers who
are getting hit by the tariffs that's
called socialization they claim to be
against that that was the enemy but they
are simultaneously putting on tariffs
that hurt the farmers and then using the
government to socialize the soybean
farmers or other farmers depending on
what which crop we're talking about in
exactly the way they say is really bad
socialism is bad the government paying
people not to grow is bad and then on
the tail end of it at some point I'm
hoping that Trump figures out a way to
get away from these tariffs and when he
does that obviously soybean exports are
going to go up and then what will you
hear from Trump i won
soybean exports are up even if it was a
thousand percent it would still only get
us back to two-thirds of the previous
soybean exports they don't understand
economics they don't understand math
they don't understand geopolitics and
Pat they are proud that they don't
understand because Trump's gonna win
again after we've been losing for so
long yeah maybe even Trump will abandon
the soy farmers start calling them soy
boys first thing you do is you go to a
socialist policy and then you completely
turn on them I don't think that's gonna
help his reelection chances in a couple
years well you got a vote to end this
insanity that's the thing because I'm a
so I don't we're almost there I know
that I've been saying I'm not talking
about 2020 until we get past 2018 what
we're very close to that and we're going
to start talking about 2020 very soon
partially because as I mentioned I've
been speaking to some individuals close
to some of the top possible Democratic
contenders for 2020 the mood seems to be
announced early so we may even have
announcements about 2020 sooner sooner
than you might imagine but you got to go
and vote today